olivier morel rebond je vous montrais
patrice parce que on avait déjà parlé de
ce formidable livre dessus des horizons
verticaux aux éditions lajouanique non
un polar en un mot on peut dire que
voilà il ya des gens qui disparaissent
qui sont tués qui parfois se suffit si
doux pendant l'impression exclusive et
ils ont un point commun je crois qu'on
peut dire ça c'est qu'ils sont tous des
dieux jean faure aux comores d'art tueur
à gages à ces tueur à gages qui se font
qu'ils sont tués donc juste retour des
choses peut-être alors est ce que c'est
un peu trop d'espacés c'est tout le xixe
qu'ils veulent c'est ça qui va nous le
dire
mais est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose comme
ça chez vous de justicier est ce qu est
ce que vous auriez eu envie parfois de
si vous voyez des gens qui ont tout qui
ont commis des actes horribles d'être
justicier offrir j'ai passé 22 ans
au ministère de la justice mais sa
justice j'ai changé de ministère
aujourd'hui sioniste de l'intérieur qui
est ministre de la police bon je pense
que probablement mon parcours
professionnel par le pour moi quoi et
justement quand on quand on applique la
loi depuis cette parité souvent ou pour
des juges peut-être plus souvent encore
pour des pour des policiers
on a parfois l'impression que la loi est
un peu impuissant tôt que les les
procédures sont telles que beaucoup de
gens passent à travers les mailles du
filet et parfois on l'a trouvé de faire
des choses soi-même zac km votre
commissariat des eaux par il a carrément
et franchit la porte il faut cher pour
ça que c'est d'ailleurs c'est de la
fiction je tiens à préciser la fiction
dans beaucoup de scènes le policier lui
même ne respectent pas la loi mais ce
qui fait aussi l'intérêt de son
évolution au fil de l'histoire
mais effectivement il ya tout un travail
autour de cette notion de vengeance coin
voilà ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure jusqu où est ce que je suis prêt
à aller pour venger quelqu'un que j'aime
que je sois flic ou voyou mais c'est
vrai que au fond on pourrait dire que la
vengeance est le thème principal de
données il ya donc ce policier on avait
raconté dans la première partie de cette
émission dont la fille a été enlevée on
veut pas raconter le reste mais il ya
aussi des gens qui veulent venger sur
d'autres disparus il ya ya ya ya
ces tueurs à gages qui sont qui sont à
leur tour
tu es donc c'est vrai que c'est il ya
des vengeances pour à divers javiera
pour diverses raisons même à divers
niveaux au fond et à un moment donné il
ya un dialogue entre le centre
deux personnages et il y en a un qui lie
à l'autre est ce que d'avoir tué ce mec
ce gars ça t'a fait du bien et la
réponse c'est non c'est non
c'est la vengeance effectivement souvent
c'est une fuite en avant
une fuite en avant est finalement
l'histoire démontre qu'une vengeance en
appelle une autre et finalement on n'est
pas sûr on n'est pas sûr du soulagement
on est sur l'expression de pulsions
violentes
il ya aussi alors aujourd'hui peut le
rencontrer ce que le cd tout à fait au
début du livre
ça se passe au nicaragua je crois mais
il y à un infiltré à qui on demande de
tuer une femme et son lait sont en
france as une vraie technique
relationnel technique qui est vraiment
utilisé par les paris marcos
sud-américains les cartels mexicains ou
colombiens ce qui sont souvent pénétrer
par des agents est ce qu on appelle ça
j'en dors covered règles de la dea
américaine est bien évidemment
ils ont le ce ils font ce qu'il faut
faire ce type de tests c'est à dire
assassiner des personnes innocentes et
dans seulement des personnes innocentes
mais suffisamment symbolique pour que ça
soit tellement horrible que si la
personne tu sais qu'elle est
suffisamment sincère et donc pas donc
pas infiltrée et là c'est une femme sans
défense avec son team ekoi rendement ils
leur font ils leur font tuer des femmes
des enfants pour s'assurer qu'ils sont
vraiment ils sont vraiment partie
prenante de la carte n il sauf forme et
je pense à ces gens qui sont infiltrés
il s'offre aux mais à quoi en learn il
faut aller jusqu'au bout faut pas vous
faire repérer ou de la peur et de la
motivation mes souhaits en policier
quelqu'un qui travaille pour un service
y compris dans l'enseignement c'est
quelqu'un qui s'y colle au gicm ans et
structuré normalement on peut dire que
ses 28 ans après voilà des pur sang ni
prix n'ont pas baissé pas des
psychopathes les usages de larmes sont
effectués dans le cadre de la légitime
défense
donc tu es quand même un soir dans un
contexte relativement froid ainsi qu'un
symptôme d'un problème
peu de déséquilibre plein tuer n'est pas
un réflexe humain normal d'un pour soi
c'est fort probablement pas dans un
cadre d'une réaction
mais tuer froidement une femme un enfant
derrière il ya quand même une pathologie
mais ils ont un but ces gens là qu'ils
aient infiltré cette voie là c'est de
faire tomber leur réseau agréé le réseau
est ce que vous dans votre carrière vous
êtes parfois poser la question est ce
que le jeu en vaut la chandelle à face
que je dois aller jusqu'au bout pour
poursuivre le but que je dois faire ou
m'arrêter parce que moralement c'est
impossible
voilà je décris un phénomène qui est
typiquement anglo saxons mais la france
a une approche de l'infiltration et du
crime qui est un petit peu plus
pragmatique dans tous les cas qui va
naître m'a moins loin dans ce type de ce
type de procès ces deux meurtres mais
effectivement dans toute guerre
clandestine ou dans tout travail
d'infiltration
il ya toujours une part une part assez
sombre triste
on a vu quand même enfin vous à raison
que cette plus anglo-saxon et chez les
douaniers avec les trafics de drogue il
ya aussi des sur la réalité des français
dans ce registre la direction nationale
du renseignement et des enquêtes
douanières qui fait justement de
l'infiltration y compris dans les pays
sud-américains pour infiltrer ces
cartels puisqu'on nous sommes concernés
indirectement puisque les go fast path à
un guadeloupéen martinique on est
concerné par ce type de trafic
je parlais du nicaragua mais le roman il
se passe à paris il passe à
saint-jean-de-luz il se passe à
versailles en saillie le même passage un
passage en espagne un passage en espagne
un passage au maroc maroc dans une
prison et puis au début ça commence
effectivement 1945 par la chute du mur
jean la chute du troisième reich et ça
l'est dans le bunker d'alain booker dit
le replay c'est des lieux que vous
connaissez alors là vous avez repéré
c'est quelque chose d'assez récurrent
dans mes polar c'est que tous les lieux
que je décris j'y étais pour justement
accentuer cet aspect visuel pour que les
gens arrivent à la fois sentir les
odeurs voir les images c'est tous les
endroits que je l'écris ce sont des
endroits où j'étais
la prison marocaine même si jules est un
petit peu grosse et voilà donc c'est la
prison de rabat où j'étais donc voilà
c'est que vous avez été dans le corps de
mes anciennes dilution de la même
variation pénitentiaire évidemment oui
quand vous décidez décrivaient des
scènes de prison mais on est sensible
elles sont prisées à la bonne la bonne
chose qu on fait ça on vous croit sur
parole
il ya aussi alors il ya versa il ya la
lanterne notamment les débris de
l'arrivée du produit ni ce qui est
aujourd'hui des réseaus dupré la
république
il a aussi visité est allé alors pas
directement les j'habitais pendant
pendant neuf ans dans les yvelines donc
j'ai habité un bonheur si à angers
valent donc je me suis promené dans dans
les bois autour du château de versailles
et son endroit que que j'adore donc bon
même si je n'ai pas été directement à
l'intérieur de la lanterne
peut-être un jour ib et
saint-jean-de-luz alors saint jean de
luz j'avais été une de façon très
épisodique et effectivement ce qui
m'avait marqué ce jour là c'est que tout
le monde aurait dit c'est c'est très
très beau c'est très ensoleillée et
comme de juste ce jour là il pleuvait
élevé et c'est vrai que cette scène où
on entend les drisses des bateaux taper
avec le soulevant avec la tempête de
l'entente paix de l'océan c'est
exactement ça et moi je m'attendais à
voir du beau temps et je me suis
retrouvé au milieu d'une tempête et on
le disait la fois précédente et le roman
est écrit avec des centres et tricot
très visuel ça vous plairait si
quelqu'un dit tiens je m'adapterai bien
au cinéma c'est quelque chose qu'ils
joueraient si je vous disais non ça
serait il ya des écrivains qui surtout
n'ont rien dit sur la passion d'écrire
une histoire c'est ça peut être une
histoire lui une histoire vue bien
humainement je crois que quelques années
qu'elle serait l'auteur de ville pas de
parfaits spatialement de polars qui ne
rêverait pas que l'histoire qu'il a pris
deux ans à écrire un gimmick mans le
temps qu'on met un an et demi deux ans
pour écrire mon histoire
un jour ne soit pas diffusée plus
largement et puis ça peut être assez
excitant de se dire finalement à l'image
comme en ce moment quelqu'un d'autre ça
va voilà comment ça va rendre
mais c'est vrai que c'est eux c'est un
petit peu le ce souhait d'un alternant
les scènes de très relativement courte
et relativement rapide et il ya des
scènes d'action des seuils
psychologiques voilà ça leur permet
d'alterner un épi de faire naître un
petit peu le suspense pour arriver
jusque là jusqu'à la libération la
libération finale mais ouais c'est vrai
que ce serait ça me parle de voir ça sur
une fille ça c'est un pouvoir qu est-ce
qui je suis qui choisiraient comme
acteur pour faire un sac butler
vous les voyez vos personnages quand
vous écrivez à wicker non oui vous voyez
les celtes bien sûr bien sûr c'est ça
fait partie
voilà ça fait partie du travail
totalement préalable que de dire voilà
tel tel personnage il va ressembler à ça
vars et ambiance à la manière de parler
aussi c'est vrai que vous il n'y a pas
la même manière de parler de policier où
il parlera de manière assez familière et
en main donné il ya une scène où
il ya le directeur de cabinet une prise
dans nos républiques qui parle avec les
résidents demain c'est pas le bien de
celle présentant le même langage que
voilà il ya le langage de la vraie vie
la vraie vie les flics les policiers et
puis après il ya le reste vous fait des
fiches pour sur vos personnages
non non non gse en fait je suis un peu
hypermnésique il y en a d'ailleurs
souvent ce qui se passe c'est que les
histoires avant de les écrire sur
l'ordinateur
je les écris dans ma tête en faisant des
reins courant quand je fais des footings
et donc c'est en courant que je déroule
ce message nous fait toujours du sport
et voilà donc en cours a jugé chris a
même moi quand même ça me permet d'être
dans ma bulle et puis des fois je me dis
tiens je fais ça fait deux trois heures
je suis parti et puis bon il est en deux
mais beaucoup d'écrivains qui va au bout
de deux scénaristes une soirée courts
soit ils font du vélo parce que c'est là
que se débloque les idées paraît-il oui
après angers après si vous les jeunes
autre technique c'est que quand je suis
plutôt de nature optimiste joyeuse même
s'il ya des passages un petit prix 5 si
le plus dur mais mais quand je quand
j'arrive à a je vais écrire un passage
un petit peu angoissant un petit peu
triste
la musique a aussi assez intéressant sur
moi c'est à dire que même si je suis pas
fatalement porté vers cette musique mais
si j'écoute des écoutes et en écrivant
si je veux me mettre dans un état
d'esprit un peu un peu triste je peux
écouter du mylène farmer par exemple les
premiers albums et après ça voilà je
mets dans cet état là l'ambiance si je
quelqu'un je suis à la fin que je veux
faire des scènes un petit peu plus
rapide de j'écoute ac dc ou des carrés
des morceaux on peut un peu rock'n roll
publié la liste des évadés décrirais
comme ça qui publie la liste des discos
planté un petit scoop les délais dernier
la dernière séquence qui sont très très
haché très rapide je les fuis en
écoutant probablement des meilleurs
albums de la cdc qui est rituelle non
plus qu'on peut se couvrir côté en vous
disant le vif s'appelle au dessus des
horizons verticaux 7 aux éditions la
joie ni et c'est donc d'olivier morel
merci merci
maurice